how closely will uncharted stick to the
games who's starring what's the story
and most importantly when can we watch
it here's everything you need to know
about uncharted cinema's influence on
video games cannot be denied from the
mountains upon mountains of game
adaptations to the medium's fingerprint
on the direction and writing of games
movies have a large hand in shaping
games as an art form some games of
course are more movie-like than others
and few studios are as successful at
making cinematic games as naughty dog
with mega popular titles like the last
of us and its sequel wearing their
cinematic influences on their sleeve the
company has built its reputation as a
premier cinematic game developer in the
world the shoe is about to be on the
other foot however as we get closer and
closer to sony's film adaptation of
naughty dog's action adventure series
uncharted the uncharted film has had a
long and troubled production history
riddled with delays but has finally
seemed to find its stride in the past
year or so
now it seems reasonably certain that
uncharted's most recent release date
will be final here is what we know so
far sony first went public with their
plans for an uncharted movie all the way
back in 2008. since then there has been
no end to the number of production
hurdles pushing back the film's actual
release in the midst of more than a few
rewrites recasts and director pass-offs
sony first announced the theatrical
release for 2016. not long afterward the
release was moved to one date after the
other including 2017 march 2021 july
2021 october 2021 and february 2022
after a certain point it seemed as if
uncharted would never be released
however after 13 years and seven
different directors it seems as if the
movie has reached the light at the end
of the tunnel the uncharted movie will
premiere in theaters on february 18th
2022 one of the biggest draws for the
upcoming uncharted film are its two
talented co-stars the original uncharted
game series focused on the adventures of
scruffy treasure hunter thief nathan
drake and his suave hustling mentor
victor sully sullivan originally the
role of nathan drake was supposed to go
to mark wahlberg however after a number
of rewrites sony decided to focus on a
younger version of the character they
then gave the role of nathan drake over
to spider-man homecoming star tom
holland however sony wasn't about to
push maki mark to the sidelines the
benefit of telling a story about a young
nathan drake is that sully is also a bit
more youthful this opens the way for
warburg to step in and assume the role
of drake's seedy father figure of course
nothing is so simple when it comes to
this movie fans have had mixed feelings
about some of the film's casting
decisions especially with regard to
sully holland could make a convincing
younger drake but woolburger sully would
take some convincing this is especially
true after rumors circulated that this
sully might not have his iconic mustache
for the entire duration of the film
evidently a stash less silly is akin to
heresy
still many fans remain optimistic about
the film's starring duo
what is that thing on your face
puberty's right around the corner kids
you can grow your own
the rest of the main cast includes
antonio banderas who will be playing
santiago moncada the heir to a wealthy
and powerful house that once lost a
fabled fortune sofia ali who will be
playing chloe frazier nathan drake's
longtime love interest who first
appeared in uncharted 2 and tati
gabrielle who plays braddock a mercenary
working against nathan and sully sony
pictures has released an official
synopsis for the uncharted movie which
reads street smart nathan drake is
recruited by seasoned treasure hunter
victor sully sullivan to recover a
fortuner masked by ferdinand magellan
and lost 500 years ago by the house of
moncada so far so uncharted the synopsis
continues what starts as a heist job for
the duo becomes a globe-trotting
white-knuckle race to reach surprise
before the ruthless santiago moncada who
believes he and his family are the
rightful heirs with the villain
introduced a perfectly cast antonio
banderas the synopsis concludes if nate
and sully can decipher the clues and
solve one of the world's oldest
mysteries they stand to find 5 billion
dollars in treasure and perhaps even
nate's long-lost brother but only if
they can learn to work together based on
the plot summary it sounds like the
movie will be very much in line with the
video games most games in the uncharted
series starts off with drake and sully
hunting for treasure or an artifact once
possessed by a famed explorer in this
case portuguese explorer ferdinand
magellan is the first man credited with
heading a circumnavigation of the planet
without fail this leads drake and sully
on a wild goose chase rife with
artifacts and mysteries until he
discovers some lost city or vast
repository of treasure based on what we
know about these versions of drake and
sully we can determine that the film
will take place prior to the main
plotlines of any of the original
uncharted games however the film likely
won't be a straight-up origin story as
the events regarding drake and sully's
initial encounter were covered drawing
flashback portions of uncharted 3. based
on the trailers it looks like uncharted
will mind the games for action set
pieces and easter eggs and will likely
be more of an homage to the games than a
missing chapter in their larger story
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luba videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you